foreign
I remember a particularly nasty
interaction where one of our detractors
took me to task for admitting that I did
not know by what mechanism Ivermectin
seemed to be working and she said and if
you don't know it must not work right
exactly how can you say that something
works without if you don't know the
mechanism of action and of course that's
not how science works at all you can
absolutely know that something works and
not know the mechanism of action but
it's frankly such a mechanistic approach
to science is almost always hand in hand
with a reductionist approach and almost
always revealing of a relatively small
mind who may generate sort of bricks in
the wall that already exist in science
but is very unlikely to discover new
truths it is a hundred percent not the
way that science has to work there is
good mechanistic science out there as I
think this paper we're going to talk
about today reveals but the idea that if
you don't know mechanism you can't know
the thing is functional no right and any
fool knows this right I mean how many
how many people how many games of
Ultimate Frisbee have taken place
entirely on a field with no nobody on it
who could explain what the relationship
is between the Bernoulli effect and the
way the damn thing flies right no you
just know how to throw the frisbee right
so anyway yeah knowing how it works it's
not essential but it's fantastic when it
happens because it allows you to go that
much farther you can extrapolate in ways
that you could not necessarily otherwise
extrapolate so anyway it's great that a
mechanism of action seems to have
emerged indeed so
um we ran it across this on Dr
McCullough's substack
he published a short piece called
ivermectin's mechanism of action against
Stars Kobe 2 described shame on the
hospital symptoms
shame on the hospital systems that
systematically denied patients and their
begging families this FDA approved Nobel
prize-winning wonder drug
he is talking about he is referring to
this paper that came out in the
international Journal of molecular
Sciences which you can show my screen if
you like Zach
um just
recently it's actually end of 2022 and
the title is SARS Kobe 2 Spike protein
induces hemagglutination
implications for covid-19 morbidities
and Therapeutics and for vaccine adverse
effects
okay
I think we had talked about me just
sharing a couple of excerpts from the
paper before we talk about it yes well
there was one other thing that was I
don't remember if it's in the paper it
was certainly in McCullough's brief
treatment of it which I wanted to remind
people of okay because there's been so
much effort put into confusing people
about Ivermectin and whether or not it
works for SARS cov2 that I just wanted
to um to highlight this uh this piece of
information which is that Ivermectin was
known to have broad scale effects
against
RNA viruses generally there's a large
number of RNA viruses in which it has
been shown to be useful so to the extent
that people are scratching their heads
over why a dewormer has an effect on
SARS Kobe 2. that's not what it is this
is a highly bioactive molecule that has
effects yes on parasitic worms also
appears to have effects counteracting
RNA viruses of which SARS cov2 is of
course one so not a lot of them and we
and we wrote that into the piece that we
published on my sub stack as well and
you know it it is
it is a kind of a wonder drug and
there's a reason that it was on the
whose list of essential medicines and
that's not Roger daltrey's doing that's
the other who and that's the who that is
since like you know taken out if Roger
Daltrey come from well you know until
2020 when you said the who most people
who weren't associated with the World
Health Organization are in that sphere
somehow I would think you know Peter P
Townsend and red adultery and such but
you know this isn't this isn't a sleight
of hand on our part going like yeah some
you know rock stars think that
Ivermectin works like no the who it's
still on their list of essential
medicines and
um I believe it's back on a number of
other health agencies list of
recommended medicines for copen2 but I
did not look into that it is actually I
checked before the podcast I have to
delve deeper to see exactly what it
means but it is actually on the NIH site
um so it wasn't actually so be careful
there because it wasn't an age site for
a while and but they basically said yeah
but not really yeah so I don't know if
something's research or something like
that but yeah anyway it's it's uh it's
beside the point I will point out that
in terms of yes you can know that
something works before you know how it
is that it works that there is also
something to be said for the integrative
aspect of this right you have a
bacterium found in Japanese soil I
believe a golf course was the original
Source no I didn't know that um but in
any case that makes it weirder in a way
it does make it weird selective effects
from the stuff you have to put on grass
to make it into a golf course either
that or it's very tolerant and uh
Satoshi omora was at the golf course
because it's a place that brings people
I don't know exactly what the
explanation would be but the thing that
I would point out is there's bound to be
a fascinating ecological
story
underlying the question of why this
bacterium has effects against a broad
range of creatures in other words if you
studied the bacterium instead of
studying the compound you might find
that it has a unique environment in
which fending off these things is
particularly relevant to some story I
think that we don't yet know and I would
love to hear that story how is it that
some
creature as inconspicuous as this one
came to have all of these effects that
we find so useful right and without
understanding why or even what yet what
many of the effects were uh the
discovery by umara uh won him a Nobel
Prize back in 2015 2015. so not that
long ago actually even though the
discovery was many decades before that
is as often the case with the I mean
maybe always the case with the Nobel
right at least in physiology and
Medicine
um that the award gets granted
um often decades after the discovery
question I think all of the Sciences
maybe peace not so much and maybe
literature not so much although
literature tends to be across for a
lifetime anyway I digress yeah
yeah neither here nor there um okay so
this article
uh published in the international
Journal of molecular Sciences finds that
and you may show my screen if you like
Zach this is just the second half of the
abstract the results of these
experiments were first that Spike
protein from these four lineages of SARS
Kobe 2 induced h a which is
um hemagglutination
assay I want to say that has to be essel
the way they've got this um
that's weird
um
Omicron induced ha at a significantly
lower threshold concentration of Spike
protein than the three prior lineages
and was much more electropositive on its
Central Spike protein region IBM it's
Ivermectin blocked h a when added to red
blood cells prior to spike protein and
reversed
hemoglutination when added afterwards
these results validate and extend prior
findings on the role of glycan bindings
of viral Spike protein and covid-19 they
furthermore suggest therapeutic options
using competitive glycan binding agents
such as Ivermectin and may help
elucidate rare serious adverse effects
associated with covid-19 mRNA vaccines
which use Spike protein as a generated
antigen so that's highly technical as
abstracts will tend to be but it clears
up a little bit with a few more a few
more sections
um and for those glycan is just a
polysaccharide
so
hemagglutinating property basically just
means clumping okay
um so this clumping of red blood cells
this hemagglutinating property of SARS
cov2 has important clinical consequences
first with trillions of red blood cells
each circulating through narrow
pulmonary capillaries about once per
minute even small dynamically
aggregating and disaggregating red blood
cell clumps as can form even in the
absence of pathogens can impede red
blood cell oxygenation
peripheral ischemia endothelial damage
and Vascular occlusion are indeed
frequently observed in serious cases of
covid-19 as reviewed in these references
in covid-19 patients damaged endothelium
of pulmonary capillaries is often
observed adjoining relatively intact
alveoli while hypoxemia is manifested
despite normal breathing mechanism
mechanics these morbidities of covid-19
parallel those of severe malaria in
which clumping of parasite infected red
blood cells to other red blood cells via
sa I don't remember what that is
terminal residues and endothelial
cytoadhesion also often result in fatal
outcomes so they are saying this looks
similar to malaria we now are seeing
what SARS cov2 is doing which is it's
causing red blood cells to Clump the
word being hemagglutination and and we
the authors of this paper are putting
together that that thing that we are
seeing with the observation the clinical
observations of how it is that people
suffering from Bad cases of covid are
manifesting in terms of their symptoms
so
um I don't know if you want to continue
there or I want to add a couple of
things so to translate some of that it
is counterintuitive that capillary beds
are actually basically composed of uh
of
arterials that are so tiny that
basically the blood cells go through
close to single file and any clumping
causes these things not to be able to
get through and what they're saying is
that that results in damage from these
tissues not being perfused with oxygen
and any tissue that is denied oxygen
long enough basically ends up dying
which they're saying matches some of the
pathologies that we see from a severe
covet infection may also say
that the lungs are failing to engage in
gas exchange even though the mechanics
are working and the basic point is in
order for gas exchange to work the blood
has to get right to this very cusp of
contact with the air that you're
breathing in and to the extent that the
capillary beds in your alveoli are not
perfused with blood cells because the
blood cells can't get in a single file
to get into those tiny little arterioles
it's not working so they're not
presumably dumping carbon dioxide and
picking up oxygen which then results in
the the hypoxia that was talked about so
much earlier in the covet pandemic yeah
uh just just a semantic Point
um so the heart
as mammals we have a fully four
chambered heart in which uh you know we
have blood coming out of the heart and
going to systemically coming back in and
then going to the other side of the
heart and going out into the Lum lungs
the lungs the lungs and then back and in
both of those circuits be it out to the
body uh and then back or out to the
lungs and then back you basically go go
out on the biggest biggest most
muscularized vessels the arteries and
then as they get smaller there's no real
category difference but like then they
become arterials and then at the point
that they are at their most at their
smallest where the blood cells May in
fact be going single file we call those
capillary beds we don't really call them
arterioles at least over in comparative
biology land where I'm you know never
dissected a human but dissect a lot of
cats
um and then you know as they come out of
the capillary beds like venules I think
veins as they get bigger you know and
veins are um are under much less
pressure and so the sides of them are
are much less thick and they tend to you
know you end up with these um pools
pools in your veins potentially if you
aren't otherwise very healthy or if
you're old in a way that you don't
really get pools in your in your
arteries because the blood coming
directly out of your heart before it
hits capillaries is under fairly high
pressure but after having gone through
the capillary beds it's coming back more
sluggishly and also deoxygenated and the
thing about the alveoli of the lungs is
that basically the lung the lungs the
the pulmonary circuit out of the heart
is is a way to get the blood back into
oxygenated state right so you know the
pulmonary artery is the least oxygenated
vessel in the body
at least oxygenated big vessel in the
body even though in general when we
think of arteries it's like oh you know
the blood is pumping fast it's full of
oxygen but only if it's recently come
back from the lung system that's now
going out into the body right and so
um so I did screw up I used arterial or
I should have said capillary but in any
case
um it's amazing how well this actually
fits a lot of the stuff that was
discussed early in in covet the hypoxia
is basically if you imagine that what
you did you know even if your red blood
cells are just uh a little bit tending
to stick together that's enough to keep
them from flowing through those
capillary beds the way they're supposed
to and so you can imagine they put that
pulse ox thing on your finger and
basically what it's reading is that to
the extent that oxygenated blood landed
in your tissues like the ones in your
fingers it burned its oxygen and then
wasn't in a position to go back and play
another round of the game
um and so you would see this now what I
don't hear explained in here is why
the you you'll remember that the
syndrome was called something like happy
hypoxics you had people who had such low
oxygenation that they should have been
on the floor and yet they didn't even
register to themselves that they were
struggling to to oxygenate so I'm
looking for I'm waiting for that
explanation yeah but uh anyway so far
interesting yeah so a few more uh a few
more bits from this paper
uh this is just something that we've
talked about before but I direct and
achieved Nobel Prize honored distinction
for Success against Global parasitic
scourges but is a disputed efficacy in
the treatment of covid-19 as indicated
for example by the disparity in the
conclusions of this editorial cited and
its key cited meta-analysis cited so
this is just so these authors like all
the authors trying to publish all the
scientists trying to publish on covid
right now who are in any way dissidents
from the mainstream narrative uh have to
have to do a little bit of this like oh
but the vaccines are great oh but you
know things don't work when we've been
told they don't work even if they really
kind of do and so there's always a
little you know there's there's ways
that you can get in the critique and
this is them doing that the conclusions
of the editorial that they cite
um are are you know we need to stop
using drugs that don't work and then the
meta-analysis and that includes
Ivermectin and the meta-analysis that
that editorial sites finds that it does
work so
um you know even even the
even the medical journals that are
supposed to be that seem to be doing the
right thing are um are are just are
citing things backwards throughout
throughout well I guess what you're
saying is you can detect the uh the
massive force that wants to tell you
what you can and cannot say even in a
paper that's reporting something here
that's clearly a Vindication of those
who have been demonized but no but no
this is them going like yeah look look
at what these guys Clarity between the
yeah yeah and but you have to you have
to I'm not going to do it here but
you're like if I did before became my
camera you have to go and looks like oh
okay so this is them
revealing something that the Casual
reader won't be revealed but it's but
it's in here okay so um
sorry about the scrolling where's the
next thing
uh h a hemoglo
hemagglutinating okay so that's just the
the tendency of the red blood cells to
stick together
the hemagglutinating inducing activity
of SARS cov2 Spike protein which is
especially potent for Omicron raises
questions as to potential risks for
Cobin 19 mRNA vaccines which use Spike
protein as the generated antigen even
though serious adverse effects linked to
spike proteins such as myocarditis are
rare
detectable levels of SARS Kobe 2 Spike
protein and S1 and serum or plasma have
been found to persist for as long as 50
days following such vaccinations
the possibility that Spike protein
migrating into the bloodstream could in
rare cases prompt such hemoglutinating
Associated Adverse Events is suggested
for example by a study of a thousand six
subjects experiencing Adverse Events
after receiving a Pfizer bioentec or
moderna mRNA vaccination which found a
significant degree of red blood cell
aggregation in the blood of 948 of those
subjects and 148 of a thousand six these
risks may be increased for younger age
groups with 301 adolescents of 13 to 18
years of age who received two doses of
the bioentec MRNA covid-19 vaccine in
one study having a 29.2 percent rate of
cardiac Adverse Events ranging from
tachycardia or palpitation to myoperic
myopericarditis wow wow yeah so what
they're saying I should say there's a
piece of conservatism in here that
doesn't that needs to be highlighted
which is that yes the spike protein has
been found up to 50 days but it's
actually been found longer than that and
we really don't know at what rate it
dissipates I remember I uh I know you're
going somewhere persists for as long as
50 days following such vaccinations
I did not click through on these links
but I remember us talking in an earlier
Dark Horse about some of the research
that was finding that it was persisting
and the research was saying you know up
to up to 50 days or something like that
and when you go into the paper it
actually says well we actually just
stopped looking after 50 days so it's
not that they are saying and then it's
gone they're saying and then we don't
know which is an important distinction I
don't know that I don't know that's the
case here but it may well be
um it is also the case that people
should remember the spike protein is not
supposed to be free-floating after these
vaccines anyway right it's supposed to
be sticking in the membrane of the cells
that have been transfected and those
cells are not supposed to be anywhere
and everywhere in the body they're
supposed to be limited to the deltoid
and the lymphatic system associated with
it where the antigen presenting cells
were supposed to pass it off to the uh
the immunological cells the bees and T
cells that learn the formula and anyway
so the point is we're talking about
design failure after design failure the
choice of Spike protein
itself dangerous why well we now know at
least one reason why which is that it
caused causes it's chemo agglutinating
inducing it's right
and
so choice of the spike protein in fact
the spike protein is showing up
independent of the cells that that were
transfected uh all of these things are
suggesting a kind of uh blood disorder
that is
mimicking malaria
um
and
now there's a whole other story that we
could get into but um but nonetheless
the idea that this is creating this
overall malfunction of the red blood
cell half of the system uh is is
profoundly disturbing yeah and
um the mechanism of action therefore uh
I don't know if you had a piece you
wanted to read or if we should just
describe it in plain English
yeah
a vibromectomy yeah we'll do this first
and then we'll translate into plain
English good Ivermectin a macro a macro
cyclic lactone indicated to bind
strongly to multiple glycan sites on
SARS Kobe 2 Spike protein blocked
hemagglutination when added to red blood
cells prior to spike protein and
reversed hemagglutination when added
afterwards which suggests therapeutic
options for covid-19 treatment using
this drug or other competitive glycan
binding agents
so
um that's that's not you know that's in
a dish right
uh but uh Ivermectin blocks
hemoglutination
before exposure and it reverses
hemoglobination after exposure to the
spike protein in a dish a petri dish
uh suggesting that given that we now
know that one of if not the primary
mechanism of action by which SARS Kobe 2
is doing damage to people is
hemagglutination
and we know separately that IBM that
Ivermectin and it's not the only one
that does it but that Ivermectin is both
incredibly safe and oops effective in
blocking or prevent blocking or
reversing hemagglutination hey it works
against coven yeah it works against
covid also potentially works against uh
vaccine Adverse Events that are caused
by Spike protein
um I will say it is if this paper holds
it is a validation of one of the
hypotheses that we explored early on
that the mechanism of action of
ivermectin might be The Binding of Spike
protein that that might be why it has
General applicability
um and there's one other thing yeah I'm
not I don't think it's
but that's not that's not what's going
on here it's not binding the spike
protein uh the question is is so you'll
also recall that with Dr Malone on the
episode that I did with him and Steve
Kirsch we talked about the fact that the
spike protein is covered in these sugars
yeah right it's covered in these sugars
presumably as effectively a cloaking
mechanism right so if it is pulling
these sugars out of the blood and
therefore being encrusted in something
that doesn't trigger the immune system
that allows it to evade the surveillance
that happens there and so anyway it's
interesting how this result seems to
line up with some of the speculating
that we did about why things functioned
the way they did early on in the
pandemic before this stuff was known so
it's kind of kind of cool it's it's very
cool
and uh
you know it's not misinformation it's
not disinformation but it's probably
still malinformation because it's true
and it makes you distrust your
government yeah yeah
um I'm not sure what we can do about
that really I mean a better government I
think better wow yeah yeah you said a
mouthful right yeah so if we had
trustworthy government then we could at
least be emotionally disturbed at things
that made you distrusted but with a
distrustful government it's hard to know
if you're just distrusting it because it
sucks right yeah you can't know if
you're paranoid if they're actually
after you exactly it's very hard to
diagnose paranoia when there out to get
you
um yeah yeah
um yes all right all right so there
um yeah I mean let's just say this this
is this is exciting for more than one
reason a it's beginning to fill in a
piece of the puzzle B it's
operationalizable yeah right to the
extent that you just go a mechanism is
cool we don't need it
often but it's cool when you got it but
it's cool it's cool when you got it and
I actually I remember I don't think
Pierre said this on the podcast but he
certainly said it to me and maybe us
privately
that as he was discovering that
Ivermectin was not only a great
preventative for covid a great treatment
for covid but it also worked uh for long
covet and and uh Adverse Events he was
like this kind of sucks because I feel
like a one-trick pony keep pointing
people to this stuff but it works right
and anyway this begins to explain why it
is that it just sort of generally useful
in this because Spike protein is such a
large part of the pathology associated
with both the disease and the the
so-called vaccines well and I think I I
read it but I glossed over it because it
was a highly technical paragraph but um
you know they also say the
hemagglutinating property of Cyrus cov2
is much reduced in Omicron and so quite
separately and I don't know I don't know
if he said it publicly but to us Dr Cory
when we got Omicron a year ago
um he said yeah you could take the
Ivermectin but it seems to be not as
effective uh with with Omicron and that
is also consistent with this finding
that Omer Khan has a lower
hemagglutinating tendency than the other
uh strains isn't it crazy when all of
the lines of evidence line up yeah
[Music]